as an optimist i
i often struggle with fatalistic
narratives about the world i am a person
that believes in our fundamental
capacity
to overcome all of our limitations i
believe in the human being as the animal
that transcends its limitations this has
become my bumper sticker this has become
my mantra right we didn't stay in the
caves we haven't stayed on the planet
and we won't stay within even the
limitations
of biology the sky is the limit dream
bigger
than ever before and yet i have to
contend
with the world increasingly that feels
like
if it bleeds it leads doom equals
gloom gloom because of the doom
that is inevitable we're all going to
hell this
fatalistic resignation that says
well between climate change and civil
unrest and pandemics plaguing the planet
the system is about to collapse these
narratives
of system failure i think
while perhaps lighting a fire under our
ass
they are ultimately self-defeating
for it serves us not to lose all
hope the minute we resign ourselves to
some kind of
horrific inevitability we invite a
nihilism
into our lived experience that that
pillages
our inner life we might as well be
dead as einstein said he who he who can
no longer stand in awe
is as good as dead now this is not some
pollyanna-ish dismissal of very real
problems
in the world need to be addressed what
this is is a dismissal of the fatalism
that invites nihilism that says that we
are screwed and there's nothing
else to do for i believe that in the
midst
of our most difficult and harrowing
moments
can also be our finest hour like the
film
apollo 13 so elegantly
conveyed on screen it is at times
of crisis sometimes that we make
manifest
our greatest capacities we rise to the
occasion to be human is to transcend
and overcome our most difficult and
existentially threatening
moments and we stand at a unique time
in history at this at this moment we
stand
before us lies you know a fork
in the road i believe and the question
is will we rise to the occasion as jamie
wheel
once told me paraphrasing something else
will we go
from problems to be solved to problems
that solve
us will the act of seizing this moment
and finding new ways of addressing old
problems be the moments in which these
existential
problems remake us and transform us will
we
rise to the occasion will we up level
ourselves will we engender a communal
experience of the astronaut overview
effect where we see
the big picture will we become inclusive
stakeholders in an incarnation and
manifestation of the african saying
ubuntu
i am because you are if we come
to realize this that we are the
alchemists we
are the music makers and we are the
dreamers of dreams and perhaps
this moment as existentially bleak
as it seems can catapult us to the next
level beyond the bumper sticker that
invites an expansion of our
consciousness can we make manifest
our potential can we become the star
children can we make
our stand
this is the moment
[Music]
lose yourself find yourself they're both
interesting and inviting invitations but
ultimately it's
make yourself make yourself here's our
chance